hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's flash and arrow Q&A a lot of
stuff to talk about
lots of firestorm as well as a lot of
you know like Diggle Green Arrow's stuff
being talked about behind the scenes so
we'll try to get to all that just to
start with the Diggle Green Lantern
stuff because everyone was going crazy
about that last week what David Ramsey
basically said is that Diggle Green
Lantern was being discussed behind the
scenes but it wasn't any kind of
confirmation that they're planning on
doing that
it's just that the idea is being
discussed the Green Lantern Corps is
like the next major franchise they could
introduce into the arrowverse you know
first they started with Barry Allen and
the flash now Green Lantern is like the
next logical step the Adams an important
character but I don't think he's quite
as important as Green Lantern logically
you expect them to start with Hal Jordan
just because there's a lot more
awareness for that character but because
it's gonna be part of like that flash
Green Lantern movie that's coming they
might want to stay away from Hal Jordan
in the arrowverse and just stick with
another Green Lantern which is where
Diggle comes in arrow plays a little
fast and loose with continuity from the
comics which I think is ok but if they
did do a Diggle Green Lantern he
probably would end up being Jon Stewart
I think the lesson we've learned from
the flashes is that people really enjoy
continuity with the comics as much as
possible sometimes because of crazy
circumstances out of your control you
can't always do things exactly the way
they were done in comics but in the case
of Jon Stewart Green Lantern I think
they'd be ok just had a tab in chrome
for like arrow season for continuing
discussion stuff there's no way that
they're gonna make a decision on that
anytime soon
I think eventually we'll get to Justice
Society and some of the crazier stuff
but first things first arrow is a crime
drama with superheroes in it so it's
always gonna be true to that first ok so
moving any questions just careful for
spoilers from arrow in the flash this
week if you haven't watched the episodes
yet so here we go Nathan HS why do some
people get powers and others didn't so
we're starting with flash stuff and then
I'll get into arrow so you're asking
about why are there some metahumans on
the flash and why are some tech based
mostly because the people that they
choose to get tech based powers or like
the really smart people who would
naturally be able to develop those Pied
Piper is a really good example they said
that because he's a genius he would have
the ability to create tech that would
give him superhuman abilities then you
have people like Clyde Martin the
original weather wizard from episode 1
clearly not a genius so if he's going to
be a villain with
it'd make more sense for him to have
metahuman abilities I think that's a
really cool idea - is it like the really
smart people that make their own
superpowers also prey on the weak people
entering the nimita like Frankenstein
monster metahumans that's kind of what
gorilla grodd is he's kind of like
Frankenstein's monster for anyone that's
read Frankenstein you'll note that that
does not end well for anyone next
question and Erik Jaffa asks what's the
purpose of the flash ring usually in the
comics it's just used to house the
Flash's costume so that he can change
into it at SuperSpeed Barry Allen and
the Silver Age comics was also able to
compress his own molecules and hide
inside the ring the TV show has not
fully explained what the reverse flash
uses his ring for and whether or not
it's a replica or it was passed down by
a previous flash it's just that in the
comics there have been a number of
different rings it's not just like one
ring that gets passed along there are
copies that are created what I'm really
hoping is is that Harrison wells is
hiding something in the ring and it
works just like it does in the comics
like something's gonna come flying out
of it next question Rishikesh asks how
come well Cisco and Caitlin find a
hardware solution in such little time so
you're asking about the the firestorm
device well you have to assume that
Harrison wells knew exactly how to build
it like he knew instantly what it was
and what he needed to do to create it
so here Harrison wells has like a
blueprint inside his head tooth they're
all super geniuses and three I mean it's
television so they need to finish the
story in 42 minutes or so so just think
of it as like a combo of an extreme
intellect and TV logic next question
Xavier asks do you think that dr. wells
will inadvertently make Eddie the second
reverse-flash no I actually think that
Barry Allen is gonna do that I think
once we get to the end of the season
we'll see like this big timeline where
Barry Allen is the originator of the
entire flash lineage including the
reverse flashes he's the point of origin
something happened in the future to
change that Harrison wells came back in
time to make sure that it happened so
that he could go back and save his wife
because if the flash was never created
then the reverse flash never happened
and it messes the entire timeline up if
you remember when Barry Allen was
fighting the reverse flash and he said
we've been at this for a long time we
don't know how long they've been
traveling through time fighting each
other so they could have changed and
fixed a lot of things already don't go
too nuts with the logic though the
show's going to completely explain
everything
especially now that we're getting into
time-traveled they'll start to explain
exactly how the show is doing time
travel next question so Jerry Rodriguez
as do you think that Eiling will become
the general you're talking about like
his comic book character with metahuman
abilities no I think that he'll probably
just be an don't you just feel
like Clancy Brown doesn't need
superpowers to be intimidating he's so
much fun to watch if he actually if you
want to see him with real superpower to
be really scary with superpowers go back
and watch carnival that was an old HBO
show okay so moving into era territory
movies rocks ass that line I can't
believe I didn't recognize my own
brother under that hood
or something along that line total nod
to Lois Lane Superman's thing yeah I
mean we have to remember that there's
like a certain suspension of disbelief
it's like they don't want everyone to
know everything just because it would be
ridiculous for the story I think that
funny moment that Thea had with him
after the fact where she was like Korean
barbecue and he was like nope ceefor and
they just kind of nodded each other they
can do funny moments like that because
of that original superhero trope where
it's like I can't believe I didn't
recognize you you were wearing glasses
next question Jordan asks do you think
that Slade will kill Thea in a future
episode I know he doesn't have mirakuru
at him anymore so he's probably not
quite as crazy I actually I think
there's more of a danger of Thea killing
Slade and Oliver freaking out remember
Oliver doesn't want Thea to go too dark
she doesn't want her to turn into Merlyn
if you look at some of the promo images
it looks like Slade is gonna force her
to kill him or force Oliver to kill him
I'll go on record as saying I hope this
doesn't happen because if they kill off
Slade they can't bring him back in a
future episode and he's just way too
interesting as a character to kill off
for good
I think they'll dance around that
somehow like somehow Slade will get away
and they won't be forced to kill him but
that is why Merlyn sent them to the
island to regain their quote unquote
killer edge next question Kathleen ass
why hasn't Diggle been fighting or
helping out seems like they haven't been
using him a whole lot lately well that's
just because the last couple of episodes
have been mostly about progressing the
Black Canary character the show just has
to pick and choose which characters that
focuses on
don't worry though there's gonna be a
really awesome Suicide Squad episode I
want to say it's number 17 in the in the
title as suicidal tendencies so that's
gonna be a big Diggle episode next
question in mind of Asian asks will
there ever be a TV Justice League coming
up once v and firestorm another possible
characters are established yeah I
definitely think there will be like a
big team-up episode I think the relative
size of the team like the number of
different characters will just depend on
how many they can afford to pay I think
it's a big goal of the producers to get
to Justice League at some point but I
think what they might do is just use it
in one of those flare Oh crossovers and
future seasons it'll be a big event
piece for the network so it is like
prime territory for Justice League
moments next question or hunter des if
Laurel is not gonna get powers do you
think that they might just make those
devices small enough so that they can be
put out on the necklace or something but
just as powerful so oh you're asking
like you know give her sudo canary cry
powers but using tech yeah I totally
think they're gonna do that it might not
happen right away but if people on Team
arrow are going to be getting text from
STAR Labs presumably other characters
will get tech as well I may have talked
about it in a previous video but if you
look at the way pipe Piper's powers work
I think that would be a good analog for
the canary cry like a sonic based device
that you can wear thank you everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do remember Manu Bennett
coming back to arrow next week so be
sure to subscribe to get that video it's
gonna be crazy like have you seen the
promo images he just has this crazy
insane look on his face it's gonna be so
much fun and because I might not get to
my spider-man Q&A I do want to do
another Spiderman Marvel video so I
might just do that next week just do it
as a separate bonus video there's plenty
more to talk about including the fact
that dylan o'brien probably gonna be
cast as spider-man don't worry
lots of fun stuff coming this weekend
everybody have fun happy Valentine's Day
oh and I almost forgot the showrunner on
Constantine said they're probably not
gonna make an announcement on season 2
until May like whether it's canceled or
renewed so just do not worry about that
anytime soon while you guys wait for
those new videos to post you can click
here to catch up on arrow in the flash
and you can click here to catch up on
the Constantine finale thank you so much
for watching so let's all high-five I'll
see you guys tonight
you